نحن الان في مدينه مجمع الاثيوبيا وهي
نقطه العبور الوحيده البريه بين السودان
واثيوبيا لا تفصلها عن مدينه قلابات سواء
عشره كيلو مترات جسر صقير يفصل بين
المدينتين حيث يتنقل
العابرون الى هذه المكان حيث وصل الى
اثيوبيا اليوم اكثر من 700 شخص فيما وصل
في الايام الخمسه الماضيه حدود 3000 من 23
جنسيه كلهم طبعا من افريقيا واسيا
ومواطنين عرب ومنهم من سوريا واليمن وايضا
وصلوا الى هذا المعبر اول مره الرعايه
السودانيين العاملين في منطقه الخليج
الذين يحملون اقامات دول الخليج فكما
تشاهدون الودع فيه اكتزام كبير لا توجد في
هذه المدينه سوى سبعه
فنادق وفي الاتجاه السوداني خمسه فنادق
وعدد الواسلين يتجاوز اكثر من 4000
الضغوطات كبيره والودع صعب والامور تزداد
صعوبه مع تدفق عدد كبير من القادمين من
السودان وايضا وصلوا الرعايه السودانيين
الذين يتجهون الى خارج السودان من سكان
خرطوم
محمد طه توكل الجزيره مهتمه